so last week we took a look at the
elgato wave panel
their take on sound paneling well this
week we're going to take a look at one
of their other new products the elgato
light strip
their take on rgbw lighting at the price
of 60 us dollars these
actually offer some pretty good
competition with the leading competitor
in this field phillips whose light strip
runs for
80 us dollars so let's see how elgato
stacks up but first make sure to hit the
like and sub button if you want to see
more videos like this the light itself
runs a length of 78.74 inches
offers a brightness of 2000 lumens and
has the color range
of 3500 to 6500k
for comparison philips lightstrips runs
the same length of 78.7
inches has a lower lumen output of 1600
but offers a wider color range of 2000
to 6500k in short the elgato light
strips offer less of a color range
but are a lot brighter than the philips
setup is pretty straightforward
you just apply the lights where you want
them using the sticky adhesive provided
on the back i went with placing it
behind my computer desk because
well i like seeing the rgb lights for
myself i've had them up for a little
over half a week now and the adhesive so
far has remained pretty strong
once you have them set up you'll need to
install the elgato control center
app either on your desktop or your phone
follow the instructions to sync your
lights to your wi-fi
and you're good to go i will say that i
did encounter an issue where the control
center app would keep crashing on the
desktop
after i set up the lights no matter how
many times i reset it
so i just ended up having to uninstall
them and reinstall it
and once i did there were no more issues
so worth pointing that out
but honestly i prefer using the phone
app anyways because you can
save up to six sets of colors as your
favorites for easy switching
which you can't do on the desktop
version however if you happen to own a
stream deck you can program that to work
with your light strips
you can set up a power button color
presets and adjust brightness and temp
it's pretty neat but kind of a bummer
that you need a stream deck if you want
to set
presets just using the desktop at the
very least the phone app is still
available and
free now one of the big selling points
of these lights is that they're supposed
to be
flicker free typically led lights can
flicker when shown on camera and you'll
need to adjust your shutter speed
to reduce this you can see this
happening here with the philips light
strip
meanwhile the elgatos do not flicker
this makes the elgato light strips the
better choice if your goal is to use
them to decorate a studio
or behind you for your at-home streaming
setup which
yeah is kind of elgato's whole deal if
you're somebody like me who likes
decorating their space in rgb
lighting then the elgato light strips
are a pretty easy recommendation from me
they're good quality easy setup and
brighter than their leading competition
the philips as well as being
twenty dollars cheaper if you're in the
market for some good led light strips i
would definitely give these a look
thank you for watching to the end of
this short but hopefully enjoyable
video if you haven't already please give
us a like and sub
like i said at the beginning it really
does help us out a lot it lets us know
that you guys enjoy these type of videos
and that we get to keep making
more videos like this one speaking of as
i mentioned at the beginning
i do have a other video on the el gato
wave panels talking about acoustic sound
paneling and what that can potentially
do for your space
so if you haven't already seen that why
not go check that out
so
you